This video was made possible by Brilliant.
Learn complex topics simply for 20% off by
being one of the first 200 to sign up at brilliant.org/Wendover.
This is one block in one city in one state
of the United States.
The US Constitution’s Article 1, Section
2 prescribes something that must happen on
this block: “Representatives and direct
Taxes shall be apportioned among the several
States which may be included within this Union,
according to their respective Numbers…
The actual Enumeration shall be made within
three Years after the first Meeting of the
Congress of the United States, and within
every subsequent Term of ten Years, in such
Manner as they shall by Law direct.”
What that means is that every ten years, the
US government must determine how many people
live on this block, in addition to how many
people live on every other block in every
other city in every other state and territory
of the United States.
They must determine the population of the
country—a straightforward task, but one
that thousands of US Census Bureau employees
spend a decade preparing for, and a year and
$15.6 billion executing.
It turns out that counting more than 300 million
people isn’t exactly easy.
Instead of looking at how the Census counts
every one of those hundreds of millions, lets
rather look at how they count the couple dozen
people living on this one city block.
The Bureau started preparing for the 2020
Census on November 1st, 2011.
They have a staff of about 4,000 who plan
and coordinate each Census, along the their
other programs, and then, every ten years,
when it comes time to actually conduct the
Census, they employ more than half a million
other individuals temporarily.
The 4,000 full-time employees, though, spend
much of the decade forming their operational
plan, the first draft of which was done in
late 2015.
They then spent the next three years refining
that.
A significant element of this plan includes
deciding where the Census’ field offices
will be located.
You see, the Census divides the country up
into six regions which are headquartered with
permanent offices in Los Angeles, Denver,
Chicago, Atlanta, Philadelphia, and New York
City.
Then, within those regions, the Census opens
up 248 temporary field offices to conduct
local operations.
These field offices are distributed based
on density so Colorado, for example, only
has four while New York, on the other hand,
has 21.
Each of these offices has to hire hundreds
or thousands of enumerators to go out into
the streets and conduct the Census.
Finding half a million temporary workers is,
of course, incredibly difficult and it’s
even more difficult for the 2020 census given
that the country currently has the lowest
unemployment rate in recent history.
In order to attract those half million people
they do have to account for the drastically
different wage conditions across the country.
Enumerators in Mesa County, Colorado, where
our block is located, for example, are paid
$16.00 per hour which, for this area, is a
pretty decent hourly wage—especially for
a low-skilled job requiring few qualifications.
Of course, if you offered that pay in New
York City, on the other hand, it would be
far less attractive so the pay there is upped
to between $25.00 and $28.00 an hour.
Despite the decent pay, though, the Census
still always has enormous difficulty filling
all their positions so they spend years teeing
up all these workers.
The first of the temporary hires for the 2020
Census happened in mid-2018.
That’s because, before the Census can go
and ask every household on this block how
many people live there, they have to figure
out where each of these households is.
In the past ten years, new houses could have
been built, structures could have been subdivided,
and plenty more could have changed so this
is a crucial step for accuracy.
In addition, if a homeless person is living
in this alley, if someone’s living in a
motorhome in someone’s driveway, or if there
are any other abnormal residences, this too
needs to be counted.
Previously, the Census would have sent someone
to walk this block, in addition to every other
block in the country, and mark down where
each residence is, which clearly took an enormous
amount of person-hours.
With the 2020 Census, though, they’re shifting
technique to use more and more satellite imagery
to identify residences.
Of course, that’s not perfect.
For example, it’s hard to tell if this is
one residence or two, so for any areas that
they’re not sure about they’ll still send
people to check in person.
At the conclusion of this process, at least
in theory, they should have a list of every
single place where people live in the US.
Also in 2018, the Census Bureau had to submit
to Congress the questions they planned to
ask the American public.
The Census is incredibly simple—after all,
it has to be if they expect everyone to answer
it.
It asks four background questions, five about
the primary resident, then seven about every
other resident of a given household.
Despite this, the Bureau spends an enormous
amount of time debating how to ask these questions.
Question selection is so complex that they
published a 98-page document explaining how
they selected the 2020 questions and their
wording.
For example, in question three, for the non-primary
residents, they added specification on whether
their relation to the primary resident was
as a same-sex or opposite-sex couple.
In the past there was the option to mark the
relation as a spouse or unmarried partner,
but there was no distinction between same-sex
or opposite-sex.
They did, however, calculate what percentage
of couples were same-sex based on how they
responded to the question asking if they were
male or female.
There was an issue with that, though.
Say there’s a married couple living in this
house consisting of one man and one woman.
If the woman accidentally marks her sex as
male and also marked her relationship as a
spouse, they would be counted as a same-sex
married couple.
Given that the overall proportion of Census-surveyed
couples who are same-sex is small, these mistakes
could significantly skew the data.
With the redesign of this question, it acts
as a failsafe so that even if the woman in
this house marks her sex as male, they’ll
still be counted as an opposite-sex couple.
These are the tiny details the Bureau has
to think about for each and every question
and change.
They have to think about how to best structure
them to get the best possible accuracy.
Once they have their questions, one of the
final things the Census needs to figure out
is how they’re actually going to ask for
responses.
Our block is located in Grand Junction, Colorado,
which is a small city, so it, along with most
of the country, simply receives a mailed invitation
instructing the recipient to complete the
census online.
This works well for most of this relatively
urban area, but not for all of it.
For example, residences in this small section
of Grand Junction will receive both an invitation
to complete the Census online and a paper
Census form.
That’s because it’s home to a number of
assisted living facilities and therefore a
number of older individuals who are far less
likely to respond online.
About 22% of the country is classified by
the Census as areas where individuals are
less likely to respond online and therefore
receive paper Census forms as well.
There are, though, areas where both of those
options won’t work.
Nearby Eagle County, for example, has a population
where one-third are of hispanic origin and
plenty of that population has limited or no
English-language skills.
Therefore, residences here receive a bilingual
invitation to complete the Census online.
There’s then one more category, used in
areas like Costilla county where there is
a large Spanish population and limited internet
access, where bilingual paper Census forms
are sent out.
The Census classifies the entirety of the
country into one of these four categories
in order to have the best possible chance
of getting an answer.
Once offices are opened, employees are hired,
residences are logged, questions are written,
and letters are planned, it’s finally time
for the Census to start in earnest.
The first Census responses cannot happen until
2020 starts, and all responses must be in
by the time 2020 finishes.
They have exactly 366 days to count every
single person in the US, and deliver that
count to the US Congress.
Our block in Grand Junction is far from the
first place to be counted though.
That happens in Toksook Bay, Alaska.
Census workers arrive there in late-January,
2020.
Toksook Bay, along with 200 or so other rural
Alaskan towns, are exceptions in the overall
timeline of the Census count as, in mid-Winter,
when the water and ground are frozen, one
can get around relatively easily on snowmobile
whereas, later on, when most of the country’s
Census counting is done, it’s very tough
to travel when the ice and snow are melting.
Down in the lower 48, the seasons are far
less of a concern so in mid-March, 95% of
American households receive a mailed invitation
to fill in the Census online.
That includes our block, but if the earlier
investigation found someone living in a mobile
home in someone’s driveway there, they would
likely get their invitation hand-delivered.
Mobile homes, residences in areas with recent
natural disasters, or households that use
PO boxes don’t get mail delivered to their
door so that’s when the Census uses this
hand-delivery technique, which is used in
about 4% of cases.
A small other proportion—less than 1%—is
visited and surveyed in person from the first
instance, mostly in the most remote areas
of Alaska and Maine, in addition to on some
American Indian reservations.
On our block, like most others, if households
don’t respond to the first invitation, they’ll
get a reminder letter, then a reminder postcard,
then a reminder letter with a paper questionnaire,
then one more reminder postcard before the
Census gives up on the household responding
by internet, mail, or phone.
Typically, about a third of the houses on
this block will not have responded on time,
even though it’s a legal requirement.
Non-respondent residences on our block will
get a visit from an enumerator, but they might
not be the first to get visited.
In-person visits are prioritized strategically.
For example, knowing that college students
will start move out from their dorms and student
housing starting in mid-May, they send enumerators
to non-respondents at college campuses first.
Each of our houses will get three visits,
then if they don’t respond on the fourth,
they’ll also try to ask neighbors if they
know the details of the residents of the given
household.
They’ll try both the household and the neighbors
again for the fifth and sixth try, but then,
if the household doesn’t respond after five
mailings, six visits, and three knocks on
the neighbor’s doors, then the Census finally
decides that the residence must be uninhabited.
Of course, in addition to counting everyone
in every household, they also have to count
people who don’t live in a household.
For example, to count homeless people, the
Census will set up at shelters, soup kitchens,
food vans, in addition to just going out into
the streets.
Another challenge is counting people who live
and work on American ships who don’t have
a permanent residence.
The Census runs a special program for this—the
Maritime and Military Vessel Enumeration—where
ships are sent Census kits including customized
forms with different questions targeted at
seafarers.
These are all then sent back to the Census
to be included in the count, and a variety
of techniques are used to assure that nobody
is double-counted.
Throughout the second half of 2020, in-person
visits will finish up, special operations
will conclude, and the Census will get into
a huge number crunching operation to figure
out, with as much accuracy as possible, what
the final count is.
They not only have to give that total number,
but they also have to break it down by state,
by county, by town, by race, by age, by relationship
status, and by much, much more.
It takes some time, but there’s a very,
very specific deadline—December 31st, 2020.
The US Congress needs to know the count by
then in order to re-allocate seats in the
House of Representatives proportionally to
the population of the states.
In the 2010 Census, 308,745,538 people were
counted as living in the US.
In 2020, the number is expected to be around
330 million but, to know for sure, we’ll
just have to wait for December 31st, 2020.
One of the big jobs at the Census Bureau is
as a math statistician and for that, according
to their job listing, you need to be adept
at things like number theory, statistics,
probability, algebra, and calculus, all of
which you can learn or brush up on with Brilliant.
Each of their courses for each of those subjects
is interactive, wonderfully designed, and
helps you learn complex topics like calculus
not through rote memorization, but rather
through breaking down the concepts into small,
intuitive chunks and then building it all
back together.
This is how you can truly understand calculus
or number theory or statistics, rather than
just learning the process to solve problems.
If math isn’t your thing, they also have
dozens of amazing other courses on subjects
like scientific thinking, quantum mechanics,
computer science, and plenty more.
To support Wendover Productions and learn
more about Brilliant, head over to brilliant.org/Wendover
and, the first 200 to sign up there will also
get 20% off.